en este vídeo vamos a hablar de la
noción de equilibrio en un contexto
macroeconómico pero primero repasaremos
brevemente lo que ya hemos aprendido
acerca de la oferta y la demanda
agregada a este eje vertical es n p el
nivel de precios de la economía que
vamos a analizar y este eje horizontal
es el pib real de esa economía
ahora vamos a trazar una curva de
demanda agregada en vídeos anteriores
hemos hablado extensamente sobre por qué
a los economistas les gusta
representarla como una curva con
pendiente descendente pero no olvides
que debemos tomar todo eso con cierta
reserva porque hay muchas suposiciones
incluidas vamos a trazar también la
curva de oferta agregada esta será una
curva de oferta agregada a corto plazo
con pendiente ascendente la llamaremos o
acp1 oferta agregada a corto plazo 1
porque vamos a analizar otras posibles
curvas de oferta agregada
entonces dadas estas curvas cuáles
serían el nivel de precios y el nivel de
producción de esta economía pausa el
vídeo y trata de averiguarlo
bien tal vez lo primero que te vino a la
cabeza fue que deberían ser el nivel de
producción y el nivel de precios
correspondientes a este punto de
intersección y si eso fue lo que
pensaste estás en lo correcto esta sería
nuestra producción de equilibrio a corto
plazo vamos a escribir lo que uno es la
producción de equilibrio a corto plazo y
corresponde al punto donde la oferta
agregada a corto plazo intersec a la
curva de demanda agregada este de aquí
será nuestro equilibrio en el nivel de
precios vamos a llamarlo np 1 ahora bien
por qué nos sentimos satisfechos con que
éste sea la producción de equilibrio a
corto plazo y este el nivel de precios
imagina lo que sucedería si estuviéramos
en un nivel de precios más bajos
supongamos que aquí podemos ver que a
este nivel de precios la demanda
agregada sobrepasa la oferta agregada
la producción requerida por la demanda
agregada es mucho mayor que la
producción de la oferta agregada a corto
plazo y eso nos conduciría a una
situación de escasez no habría
suficiente producción para cubrir toda
esta demanda y qué sucedería en una
situación como ésta bueno pues la gente
que se encarga de la producción
probablemente diría voy a cobrar un poco
más por mi producción y cuando esté
cobrando más va a decir tal vez no sea
mala idea producir un poco más así la
oferta agregada empujará de nuevo hacia
el punto de equilibrio del lado de la
demanda la gente diría no estoy
obteniendo la producción que necesito
estoy dispuesto a pagar más por ella
pero a medida que el costo de esa
producción aumente la demanda disminuirá
y terminaremos volviendo al punto de
equilibrio ahora supongamos que por
alguna razón estamos en un nivel de
precios por encima de np 1 en este caso
la oferta agregada a corto plazo es
mucho más alta que la demanda agregada
así que tenemos más producción
que está siendo demandada y que podría
suceder bueno la gente que se encarga de
la producción dirá voy a cobrar un poco
menos por mi producción y va a producir
menos de manera similar los demandantes
dirán hay un exceso de producción voy a
pagar menos por ella pero a medida que
empiecen a pagar menos dirán quiero más
de esa producción y regresaremos al
punto de equilibrio ahora bien hasta
ahora hemos hablado del equilibrio a
corto plazo y seguramente te estarás
preguntando pero qué sucede a largo
plazo en vídeos anteriores hemos hablado
de la oferta agregada a largo plazo así
que supongamos que esta es la curva de
oferta agregada a largo plazo oa lp el
punto donde intersec a el eje horizontal
es de efe y podemos verlo como la
producción cuando la economía tiene
pleno empleo en realidad es la
producción sostenible de esta economía
en pleno empleo y lo que sucede en esta
parte de la gráfica es que nuestro
equilibrio de la producción a corto
plazo se encuentra por debajo de la
de pleno empleo así que tenemos una
brecha una brecha negativa de la
producción con pleno empleo a nuestro
equilibrio de producción y si queremos
imaginar esto en el contexto del ciclo
económico en qué parte del ciclo
estaríamos dibujemos el ciclo económico
ahora el eje vertical va a ser el nivel
de producción real este va a ser el pib
real y el eje horizontal va a ser el
paso del tiempo este es el tiempo
entonces en cualquier punto dado del
tiempo va a haber un jefe producción con
pleno empleo o sea una producción
potencial sostenible para esa economía y
con sostenible nos referimos a que la
gente descansa adecuadamente y no hay un
agotamiento de los recursos entonces por
ejemplo en este punto del tiempo puede
haber un jefe y quizá unos años más
tarde la población ha aumentado hay más
infraestructura y una mejora de
tecnología por lo que podemos producir
más de una forma sostenible y tal vez
unos años después de eso
podemos producir aún más la población
crece y piensa en mejores formas de
organizar los recursos de su economía la
tecnología mejora y entonces podemos
imaginar un mundo en el que la
producción con pleno empleo podría
crecer de una forma tan buena como esta
pero sabemos que esa no es la manera en
que las economías reales funcionan todas
experimentan el ciclo económico y el
ciclo económico se parece más a esto a
veces la gente se refiere a él como
ciclos de auges y caídas porque están
llenos de cimas y valles las partes de
estas curvas donde tenemos un aumento
del pib real como aquí o aquí
o aquí se conocen como expansiones esta
es una expansión económica las partes
donde el pib real disminuye por ejemplo
aquí y aquí se conocen como recesiones
vamos a escribirlo recesiones
pero volvamos a nuestro mundo de ofertas
y demandas agregadas este punto de
equilibrio de 1 a qué punto de la
gráfica del ciclo económico
correspondería vamos a ponerle su nombre
este es el ciclo económico pone en pausa
el vídeo y trata de analizar a qué punto
correspondería bien estamos en un punto
donde la producción de equilibrio en el
corto plazo se encuentra por debajo de
nuestra producción con pleno empleo es
decir nuestra producción potencial plena
sostenible entonces esto correspondería
algún punto en el que nuestro pib real
se encuentre por debajo de esta curva
azul que parece una recta por la manera
en que la frase entonces de uno podría
ser por ejemplo este punto o este o este
otro si este punto fuera uno
este otro sería efe para ese momento
dado
ahora bien el punto jefe puede irse
incrementando a medida que avanzamos en
el tiempo y ocurre este crecimiento
económico en el que la población crece
tenemos una mejor tecnología etcétera
etcétera pero tal vez estés pensando
bueno y qué pasa con los otros puntos
hay otros escenarios posibles mi
respuesta es por supuesto imaginemos un
mundo donde el equilibrio de la
producción está a la derecha de nuestra
producción potencial y vamos a
construirlo con una curva de oferta
agregada a corto plazo diferente también
podemos desplazar la curva de demanda
agregada pero esto lo haremos en
próximos vídeos por ahora vamos a trazar
otra curva y vamos a llamarla oa cp2
oferta agregada a corto plazo 2 ahora
este es nuestro equilibrio de la
producción de 2 y corresponde al nivel
de precios
np 2
qué está aquí observa que aquí también
hay una brecha pero es una brecha
positiva porque nuestra producción real
está por encima de nuestra producción
sostenible entonces por ejemplo esto
correspondería a tal vez este punto del
ciclo económico si es así y este punto
es de 2 entonces este otro sería nuestro
jefe actual de hecho no hice el
desplazamiento pero espero que hayas
entendido la idea general y tal vez te
estés preguntando cómo podemos producir
más allá del pleno empleo cómo podemos
producir más allá del potencial
sostenible bueno esta es una economía
que produce de una manera insostenible
el desempleo es muy bajo y hay recursos
que se agotan porque la gente trabaja
demasiado y vive estresada porque no
descansa adecuadamente de la manera en
que quieras pensarlo esto no se
considera sostenible luego tenemos un
tercer escenario donde el equilibrio de
la producción a corto plazo es igual a
la producción de pleno empleo
ese podría ser este escenario donde esta
curva sería ocp3 la oferta agregada a
corto plazo 3
observa que aquí nuestro equilibrio de
la producción de 3 es igual a nuestra
producción de pleno empleo cuando esto
sucede se le considera un equilibrio a
largo plazo vamos a escribirlo esto es
un equilibrio a largo plazo
y los puntos que corresponderían a un
equilibrio a largo plazo dentro del
ciclo económico serían este este
este y este
vamos a terminar aquí en próximos vídeos
analizaremos cómo se desplazan la
demanda agregada y la oferta agregada a
corto plazo y cómo se relacionan con las
fases del ciclo económico nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo